in this video I want to talk about the
lac operon so what is an operon an
operon simply is a DNA segment with an
operator a promoter and these things
called structural genes that function in
a highly coordinated manner so the lac
operon is an inducible system so
transcription of this gene of the genes
involved in lac operon is normally off
and it can be turned on right which
means it can be induced now what is the
lac operon even involved in why do we
care about it at all well this is the
way that prokaryotes if they want to use
the lac operon black operon is involved
with using lactose for energy so if you
recall lactose is a disaccharide made up
of glucose and galactose so bacteria can
use this for energy and but they have to
break lactose down into glucose and
galactose so the enzyme that catalyzes
that reaction is called beta
galactosidase so this here is the DNA
segment concerned with all that this is
the lac operon so the lac operon has a
bunch of different important features
and that's we're going to mention here
the first of which is this here this
first portion of the DNA is called the
regulatory gene this is the regulatory
gene now in the case of the lac operon
this is an inducible system which is why
this eye is here this I represents
inducible now specifically this
regulatory gene in the case of the black
operon encodes for
sir protein which we'll talk about in
more detail shortly this regulatory gene
can in other cases encode for an inducer
protein but we'll talk more about that
in the later video the CA P site here is
the Kitab the CA P stands for Khattab a
light activator protein we'll talk about
that in another video as well qhattab a
light activator protein this P here
stands for the promoter I'll actually
want to write that up up here so
promoter now why is a promoter sequence
important why do we care about that will
recall remoter sequences bind the RNA
polymerases so if this gene is going to
be transcribed it's going to bind here
at the promoter this o here stands for
operator which you mentioned just a
moment ago this is the operator now the
operator is important because what it
does is it binds either the repressor
protein or or an inducer protein oops in
the case of the lac operon of course
since this this gene here encodes a
repressor protein the operator will bind
the repressor protein but in a system in
which this regulatory gene encodes an
inducer it inducers can bind operators
as well so now what are these three
things here Z Y and a these are all what
we call structural genes now why are
these things important these all encode
for proteins involved in breaking down
lactose for energy breaking down and
using lack'd or lactose as an energy
source that's what these genes are
important for so each one of these
actually encodes its own gene the Z
encodes for beta galactosidase which we
mentioned just a moment ago
galactosidase the Y encodes were a
permeates protein and the a encodes for
acetyl transfer light acetyl transferase
now all of those enzymes are important
in getting this process to go to break
down lactose and using lactose as energy
okay so the lac operon is a regulated
operon and it specifically it's
inducible so it's dependent upon
environmental changes and it's involved
in using lactose for energy so there are
two scenarios then we want to consider
the first one is when there's no lactose
around lactose or a low lactose so in
the case lactose or a low lactose is the
inducer of the system which we'll talk
about in just a moment but if there's no
lactose around there is no inducer okay
so what's going on when there's no
lactose around let's think about this
okay so first thing that happens is this
regulatory gene is transcribed and it
gets this mRNA
Miam RNA is translated into a repressor
protein monomer once four of these
monomers are formed they form the
repressor protein lift which is
functional and it's actually a tetra mer
now what happens is this repressor
protein it goes and where is it supposed
to bind
it's supposed to bind at the operator so
that's actually what happens the op the
operator is bound by the repressor
now once this repressor protein is bound
here this repressor protein blocks RNA
polymerase that binds at the promoter
this is RNA polymerase here if RNA
polymerase is bound at the promoter this
repressor protein stops transcription it
represses transcription so the RNA RNA
polymerase here is physically blocked ok
so RNA polymerase blocked by the
repressor protein so it's actually
physically blocking it so RNA polymerase
wants to go ahead and transcribe zy and
8 which are the genes that break down
and use lactose for energy but the
repressor protein is balanced so it
won't now why is that so actually let's
talk about what what happens here so
first important thing is that there is
no transcription of the structural genes
in this case right zy and they are not
going to be transcribed because RNA
polymerase can't get there because it's
blocked by this repressor protein so we
have no proteins to break down lactose
they're not being transcribed and
they're not gonna be translated if
they're not transcribed now why is this
well there's no lactose right there's no
lactose to break down so does this make
sense so there's it does right there's
no need to make those proteins that
break down and use lactose for energy if
lactose is not available okay so in the
case of no lactose we don't need to
transcribe these genes or not we but the
prokaryote itself doesn't need to
it doesn't need to make these these
proteins to break down lactose so
there's no lactose around now what if
there is lactose when there is lactose
there is the inducer lactose or a low
lactose specifically so when there is a
low lactose those the this inducer is
around so same idea happens as far as
this regulatory gene goes it's
transcribed and then it's translated and
the monomer becomes a tetra now this
tetra mer this repressor protein is is
functional
but there is an important nuance here
and that is that we have these little we
have lactose now so if we imagine these
little pink dots to be lactose what
they're gonna do is they're gonna
actually bind the repressor protein so
if the repressor protein was initially
bound at the operator and suddenly
lactose becomes available it's gonna
bind the repressor protein and cause the
repressor protein to hop off of the V
operator so let me go ahead and label
this as lactose here this lactose binds
the repressor so lactose is of course
the inducer sometimes known as the co
inducer so now nothing the repressor
protein is not going to bind at the
operator so what can happen RNA
polymerase binds at the promoter and it
goes it can transcribe so it's going to
go through and transcribe these
structural genes so these structural
genes become mRNA for the zy na genes
respectively and then they're turned
into proteins now these proteins these
can now break down lactose for energy
because there's lactose around right
because lactose is present and available
that makes sense right so it would make
sense that lactose is the inducer in
this case it causes the transcription of
the genes that break it down and use it
for energy okay
so that's the idea here that's how
changes in the cell's environment right
view availability or lack thereof
lactose affects the transcription of
this gene hope that video was helpful
and understanding the lac operon one
last thing I am a tutor if you live in
Southern California feel free to contact
me via email at move University at
gmail.com see the description below for
more details thank you for watching